hi i'm tom pike executive producer of
the sci-fi series personal space it's
about astronauts who have no idea their
therapy sessions are being broadcast on
earth as reality TV personal space is a
digital series that will be distributed
solely on the internet anytime you make
content for the internet you're
competing with all kinds of other things
other web shows cat videos even
listicles you have to remember that your
content has to be competitive with that
because people can switch away from what
you made at any moment I've seen a lot
of smart people try to do a very silly
thing which is to try and make web shows
that don't actually work in the web
space people like me grew up watching
films and TV and now that we're making
our own material we're trying to
recreate the things we saw as kids that
tends to lead to people making web shows
that look like cheap TV I don't think
that's a necessary result I think web
shows can be used to tell beautiful
stories there's not the same stories you
tell on a television show and you
wouldn't tell them in the same way let
me explain what I mean using personal
space as an example personal space is
shot vlog-style meaning in the style of
a video log we're on board a spaceship
and we're seeing the crews therapy
sessions from the perspective of their
therapy computer we hear about events
taking place all over the ship and we
experience an expansive story but we
stay focused in one room a classical
unity of place it's almost like a stage
play in that way this conceit lets us
create a show that looks as good as
anything on TV by eliminating expenses
and complications that are unnecessary
of the story it is a concept designed to
work with its medium rather than against
it here's an example of how not to do
web shows also from my own experience I
once wrote a space pilot for a TV show
that was full of explosions and
adventure and when my frequent
collaborators loved it we tried to scale
it down into web stat web show so that
we could make it
it had tiny explosions and tiny
adventure and if we'd actually ever
ended up making this thing it would have
just looked cheap we'd have spread
ourselves thin across a dozen sets and
visual effects it's better to do a
couple of things excellently than a lot
of things badly the digital medium has
constraints you have to deal with short
attention spans so your show needs to
have episodes that are three to seven
minutes long tops and you have to be
able to make your show work on a small
budget but there's a Zen to this
realizing that those constraints are not
bad
you just have to stop fighting against
them turn them into an ally instead of
an enemy for example when you only have
five minutes to tell a story every
choice you make matters which is awesome
people sometimes get bogged down in
questions when I tell them we're gonna
be shooting a hundred and seventy
minutes of content for forty five
thousand dollars they assume that I'm
gonna need to build all these sets and
do these company moves and and shoot all
these action sequences that we we don't
need to do in fact we couldn't tell the
story that we want to tell if we did do
these things so if you want to make
great digital content free yourself of
these questions ask yourself instead
what assets do I have maybe you have a
great camera a location you can use for
free in a talent for creepy sound design
that's awesome now here's a challenge
make a show that uses those things and
only those things this is like the old
literary challenge known as a lipeh
Graham where you try to write a novel
without using the letter e it's totally
possible it just requires you to be
inventive suppose the letter E cost you
five thousand dollars every time you
went to type it you'd ask yourself do I
really need this word that uses the
letter E or can I use another word
instead personal space would never have
occurred to us while we were still
trying to tell a story with missiles and
explosions and it's much more beautiful
not to mention original then what we
would have done if we'd had more money
and we never stopped to ask ourselves
what do we really need in order to tell
a good story your things I need may be
different from my things I need by
having a character study confined to a
single room we didn't need grips we
didn't need trucks or location managers
we didn't need to build an entire
spaceship interior what we do need is a
compelling visual reason to keep
watching we're only building one set so
that set has to look amazing and we're
staring at actors faces the whole time
so those actors have to be incredible
but that's the beauty of it
once you've freed yourself of the
unnecessary things you can focus on the
things you do need and make them top
rate in your case that could be a great
lighting designer or a wonderful
composer for personal space our set and
our cast will be TV quality casting
personal space was a 10-month process
it's tough when you're reaching out the
TV talent and none of them know who you
are but we knew what we wanted we were
patient and this is not optional
we had great scripts our
concept also means that each character
is gonna have a ton of screen time then
the actors knew from the way it was
written that we wouldn't be trying to
hide story problems under dazzling
visual effects or blaring sound design
they were going to be asked to do
character based drama and character
based comedy which is what a lot of them
got into the business to do in the first
place so we ended up with a cast I grew
up seeing on TV and we can afford them
because we ditched the things we don't
need of course we do still need some
money and that brings us to crowdfunding
because we focused on our cast there
front and center in our crowdfunding
campaign for personal space if you were
focusing on your psychedelic visuals
than you want your concept art in that
place focus on the essentials then make
those essential things great and the
same crowdfunding approach could work
for you when you're prepping a project
you intend to crowdfund it forces you to
think about what it is that actually
excites someone about your project keep
those things make them awesome ditch the
rest in the end nothing will be shown on
the screen that is not TV quality and
we'll have done it for $45,000
so that's how you make a webseries look
as good as television by not trying to
make it the way you make television
personal space is crowdfunding now we
hope you'll join us in space